ils peuvent maintenant l'afficher après
l'avoir gardé des mois dans le secret
Smart c'est donc le nom de baptême de
celle que tout le monde appelait déjà la
Swatch mobile pour le moment un terrain
vague de 70 hectares à embar proche de
Sarreguemines en Moselle dans deux ans
une usine ultra-moderne aura émergé de
cette terre et emploiera 2000 personnes
la co-entreprise dirigée par les
présidents de Swatch et de Mercedes
fabriquera alors sa première voiture
microcontact voilà à quoi elle
ressemblera ce prototype s'approche de
la version finale largeur à mètre 40
longueur 2 mètres 50 4 motorisations
possibles dont une hybride électrique et
diesel la commercialisation elle aussi
sera originale certains envisagent déjà
de la vendre dans les supermarchés on
est prêt à les vendre dans les
supermarchés s'il le faut seulement si
les conditions que nous posons possède
voiture l'environnement qui est autour
de la voiture la façon de de faire que
la joie de vivre la provocation tout ce
qu'il faut autour de cette voiture
ils acceptent de le faire pendant autour
de la voiture une voiture de petite
taille loin de la vocation première de
Mercedes qui choisit là une nouvelle
orientation Mercedes a beaucoup de
clients et beaucoup de ses clients ont
décidé d'acheter une voiture différente
voiture beaucoup plus petit et nous
sommes absolument sûr que nous avons une
bonne chance pour développer une nouveau
segment de marché un marché qui en plus
des 2000 emplois créé sur le site
ouvrira également ses portes à de
nombreux sous-traitants du secteur
automobile nous avons vu venir la chose
et nous sommes en train d'agrandir votre
sauna d'Israël qui sont les deux hommes
avec hectares aujourd'hui remplis à 90%
c'est pas mal on a l'impression d'un
Fisher Price vous savez les jouets pour
enfants avec un jouet à deux places
conçu pour la ville et qui coûtera un
peu plus de 60000 francs cette voiture
roulera dès le printemps 98 sur les
routes d'Europe
[Musique]